[Music]  underoos everyone  I get to keep the suit of course doesn't  fit me just don't do anything I would do  and definitely don't do anything I  wouldn't do  there's that little gray area in there  and that's where you operate what's up  guys wait a minute  you want the real Avengers  but this does not mean you're an Avenger  okay so we're wondering oh that's not a  hug I'm just grab the door for you  oh all right kid good luck out there the  world's changing boys time we changed to  missing Peter  forget the flying monster guy  there are people who handle this sort of  thing Oh sick of you treating me like a  kid but you are a kid this is my chest  prove myself  don't mess with me because I will kill  you and everybody in your love  listen new top no you seen that before  no with that skirt you should probably  stop staring with Laurie cos creepy  though too late  [Music]